825 membres d'une même famille tu as une
tête grande famille ah non moi je
connais personne je peux enfin j'ai ma
mon arrière-grand-mère a été trouvé sur
parvis d'une église petit bébé donc on
sait pas qui est le père de mon père
enfin voilà mon arme généalogique j'ai
plein plein de trous dans mon argent
que je connais pas du tout tu tu tu tu
tu
as raison mais c'est bien parce que ça
permet de rêver je suis peut-être la
fille d'une petite fille d'une princesse
joyeuse faut prendre faut voir le bon
côté tu as jamais essayé de chercher
d'une église tu sais c'était dans le
temps
les bébés comme ça
les filles riches
et elle laissait les bébés sur le parvis
de ce qu'on les appelle
Sicile impératrice on le sait pas mais
non mais moi j'aime bien rêver à ça
[Rires]
alors
surtout pas envie de te connaître
il y a beaucoup de choses illégitimes
qui se sont passées d'un côté donc on
évite d'en parler il y a une boîte avec
les secrets mais jamais on l'ouvrira
alors oui on descend en fait mais je
peux pas donner son nom parce qu'il y a
contestation on descend d'un maréchal
napoléonien très grande famille et en
fait c'est dégradé après
choukart il s'appelait en allemand il a
inventé un Astron droit un
austro-hongrois il a inventé des trucs
dingues j'ai pas le droit de le dire
mais je vais pas avec le secret il a
inventé chocolat le moteur explosion
tout la montgolfière on n'a jamais
touché une tune arrête arrête tes blindé
arrête
il a inventé la montgolfière c'est les
frères Mongolfier qui vont arriver le
chocolat chocolat
on devrait être milliardaire et comme il
se foutait
[Rires]
de tout il a bradé les brevets un jour
je vous emmènerai un des brevets pas de
soucars alors non je crois qu'on a le
moteur explosion un truc de dingue je
connais personne voilà par contre je
pense qu'il a inventé la connerie
Manosque ça veut dire Emmanuel ah
d'accord ouais c'est ça et non moi j'ai
de la j'ai pas mal de famille en Grèce
mais je les vois peu souvent et je suis
pas hyper famille donc du coup j'ai
recréé ma petite famille ta famille et
ma famille on est trois c'est moi mon
compagnon et mon chien et on est tous
les trois et on est bien on est bien
tous les trois c'est vraiment une
famille mais à trois on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir tant de monde que ça pour être
heureux et
je suis une famille éloignée oui éloigné
mais ça commence je commence il ne tient
qu'à toi de de te rapprocher de moi en
me faisant venir par exemple tous les
soirs
moi c'est une belle famille de l'autre
côté de ma maman ils sont quatre frères
et sœurs et du côté mon papa ils sont 7
frères et sœurs donc c'est une grosse
grande famille et éparpiller dans le
monde il y en a au revoir au Canada
dans les Montiers je connais pas sur le
Montiel que je connais il nous a fait
perdre la Coupe du monde
j'ai entendu j'ai entendu mon ciel va
tirer le penalty ils ont appelé Bernard
Montiel il y avait un joueur final de la
Coupe du Monde il s'appelait Montier
avec mon frère dis-moi celui-là même
jusqu'à la Coupe du monde il va nous
casser la tête sans rigoler c'est un
truc de fou ce mec là numéro 4 les gens
tombent je connais très bien j'ai une
très grosse on trompe de père en fils et
donc
il y a des gens
[Applaudissements]
et les noms de famille ça veut dire
quelque chose ah oui bien sûr bien sûr
attends
grec ça veut dire dur
je vous laisse à votre imagination
[Musique]
[Rires]
le crépuscule tu vois le voilà
normalement non
[Rires]
on va regarder parce qu'on a fait tout
ça pour ça
descendants de la famille des deux
fontaines masse soit 5 générations
présentes à cette cinquième cousine les
anciens nous ont laissé dans les
testements réunissez-vous le plus
souvent possible et faites des fêtes
voilà donc et faites de l'entraide
surtout et forcément pour réunir autant
de monde les organisateurs s'y sont pris
à l'avance quasiment 12 mois avant
l'événement via les réseaux Facebook
Instagram notre site internet la
prochaine cousinade de la famille est
prévue pour 2027 et tous espèrent être
encore plus nombreux
ils sont malins parce qu'ils ont fait
une sorte de bureau d'entraide et donc
en fait si tu cherches un emploi tu
cherches un logement etc c'est comme une
sorte de Minnie
mais c'est toujours l'anniversaire de
quelqu'un ah oui
il y a rien
tu as raison
Amélie
je sors de la famille